denkst du hast mich jetzt noch brauchte
ich nicht bekommst du eben habe jetzt
das versprechen herzlich willkommen beim
neuen video
ja und zwar heute bin ich dran würde ich
sagen das video ich hatte letztens hier
seine haare gefärbt von emi ich weiß ob
ihr noch kennt wahrscheinlich schon also
der der dann aussah wie ein bierkutscher
kontroverses an der sonnenblume auf
jeden fall haben wir gesagt wenn dieses
video 20009 15.000 115.000 likes riecht
dann darf er das auch bei mir machen das
ding ist also ich hab gesagt du kannst
eigentlich gerne was ausprobieren nur es
wäre cool wenn ich vielleicht wieder zu
meiner natur haarfarbe zurückkehren weil
ich hab halt vor mir andere haare zu
machen also das werdet ihr demnächst
sehen
das wird hoffentlich geil kann ich nicht
sagen aber ich hoffe es und ja ich bin
gespannt er hat halt so was so dunkler
bisher also so ein up dunkler oder ein
heller sondern ab dunkler das machen wir
jetzt einfach dieses video wo ich das
gesagt habe wenn das 15.000 ich hab
einfach so 22.000 gemacht also hat mich
sehr gefreut wenn dieses video 27.000
macht dann mag seine habe ja eigentlich
gar nicht langsam anfangen direkt an und
metzger
das macht man am besten
das ding ist du eigentlich ist mir das
scheißegal weil ich wieder zum friseur
und macht die krasse habe mainz das wird
gut
ich habe eine heftige idee was heißt die
idee das schon sie durchaus nicht
dann stehen wir dann zählt also leid ich
war dazu kommt ein video nicht doch ich
glaub nicht woche donnerstag kommt dass
das bestimmt irgendwie zeigt man die
verpackung die schule jetzt gerade
einfach alles drauf gemacht
doch wie soll ich anfangen das beste
ergebnis bei mir ist das egal eigentlich
jeweils zum friseur aus aber wenn du
wenn du so richtigen quatsch gemacht
hast dann nachher kann der friseur
daraus nicht was gutes machen
sonntag
das ist das niveau ist das bitte dunkel
dass wir nichts hält nein das wird nicht
hält das ist so das ist so wenn man
vorher schon hatte und dann sich wieder
diese rückkehr um machen gegen wen ist
ein gutes gefühl leute aber jetzt kommt
erstmal alufolie oder bin ich mal
gespannt wie lange bis wir warten 20
minuten eine halbe stunde halbe stunde
ja damit das richtig schön brauchen
dieses wort viel länger ist gerade 20 25
bis 20 uhr 20
ich hab mich so lange zeit massiv
zehntel vor bis gleich so leicht haben
jetzt 20 50 das heißt 25.01 eingewirkt
mehr wie schnell 24 minuten das
verabreichen gehen metzger umfeld
maschine silber schon mal was du
wusstest schüler schaffen keinen sinn
längste weil ich jetzt wahrscheinlich
dass wieder dunkel ist natürlich dass
dies wirklich sehr auch aus wenn ein
geld das wird das wird auf jeden fall
noch dunkel
das war so mach dir keinen kopf publikum
für das jetzt schon geboren ist das lila
geworden dahin ist es dunkel hell oder
dunkel hellgrünen dunkelgelb ja das soll
aber dunkelbraun werden dunkelblond das
wäre etwas anderes rein gemischt ist
heute ganz ehrlich es juckt mich
überhaupt nicht bin ich bei meinem
bruder matthias denkst du hast mich
jetzt brauchte ich nicht ob du kommst
fünf kleine hase
daneben waren morgen sonntag ich kann
man so sagen
das war eine kleine rache aktion von das
war eine kleine rache aktion von mir das
ergebnis
das ergebnis seht ihr dann auch beim
channel tut mir leid dass das kaltwasser
aber link ist eine beschreibung
bis gleich